c'est la sphère des dîners de
pierre-jean chalencon au palais vivienne
est devenu une véritable affaire d'état
pour la faire dit des dîners kandestin
ces dîners clandestins à paris à bout
des dîners dans un luxueux restaurant
dans la capitale vendredi m6 diffusait
un reportage où l'ancien collectionneurs
déclaré avoir l'habitude de dîner avec
certains ministres et il est fait
semaine dans deux ou trois restaurants
avec un certain nombre de mini il
s'était rétracté un peu plus tard face
au tollé qu'avait provoqué ces
déclarations car j'en avais donc mis ça
sous le coup d'une mauvaise farce
c'était un énorme poisson d'avril et
pierre-jean n'a pas vraiment convaincu
sur cette nouvelle version notamment sur
le nombre de convives qui était de 9
puis de 20 personnes au maximum
hier m6 a confirmé dans un communiqué
qu'il y avait bien une quarantaine de
personnes lors de leurs reportages et
que d'autres sources ont confirmé en off
la présence de moi un membre du
gouvernement un de ces dîners alors
quelles personnalités étaient présentes
les convives ont-ils dû payer ce soir
bruno serveurs de la soirée a décidé de
nous dire toute la vérité
et oui cette affaire qui fait trembler
toute la france un roulis on va avoir
des infos dans un instant puisque bruno
on a choyé votre prénom
vous étiez serveurs à la soirée du jeudi
1er avril
vous y étiez c'est pas faux témoins je
vous le dis c'est un vrai témoin vous
pourrez vérifier
vous avez choisi de préserver votre
identité pour éviter d'avoir des
problèmes pour continuer à travailler
aussi vous êtes serveurs dans des
soirées comme ça on vous appelle vous
travaillez voilà en freelance pour c'est
plus dû au black mais à d'accord c'est
le chômage
d'accord d'accord mais alors pourquoi
déjà la première question c'est on se
demande tous pourquoi vous avez choisi
de témoigner sur cette affaire quand
j'ai vu tout ce qui se passe en ce
moment dans l'actualité
j'estime que ces personnes-là doit
assumer un peu leurs actes parce que
c'est pas parce qu'ils ont appelé le
pouvoir et connaissent du monde chez
voilà foster parce que moi j'ai déjà eu
des problèmes au et c'est donc le
premier à me faire taper sur les doigts
donc je pense que c'est meryl ça
d'accord
alors donc vous avez travaillé en tant
que serveur d'orgue lors de cette soirée
du 1er avril
comment est ce qu'on vous a contacté
parce que déjà comme c'est une soirée
qu'on destine entre guillemets comment
vous a contacté en fait quand
sa part moi j'ai un ami à moi qui qui
qui travaillent souvent c'est que ce
style de la soirée d'accord il m'a
contacté qui m'a proposé bassin job là
pour un soir parce qu'elles n'étaient
pas disponibles donc enfin deux stars
remplacement d'accord ok m'a mis en
contact avec la personne qui s'occupe
d'organiser la soirée
j'ai été contacté par cette personne là
alors il parait qu'il ya très peu de
traces écrites à préserver une certaine
discrétion dont coupât de cmed pas de
bons on m'a appelé en basque est
d'accord donc on va faire un entretien
par téléphone
kalt aurait une vingtaine de minutes
d'accord et ensuite on m'a dit ben je
t'appelle demain centrait pour 15h30 et
je te donne je te donnerai la grâce à ce
moment là alors il faut savoir aussi je
vous le dis beaucoup d'ouvriers qui leur
donne l'adresse suivante une heure avant
la soirée vraiment c était au dernier
moment nous ont appelés à quelle heure
vous un placard à l'endroit 15h - 15
exactement d'accord ah oui d'accord
alors donc là on vous dit que la soirée
elle est où on me donne juste l'adresse
donc l'adresse c'est quoi c'est rue
vivienne 88 rue vous savez que vous
allez hop à lévis viennent pas du tout
je connais pas du tout à la base je
connais pas du tout à fait d'accord donc
vous arriver qu'est ce qu'on vous dit à
l'entrée directement on prends mon
téléphone
on ne demande de l'éteindre j'ai mon
téléphone va dans une boîte avec
d'autres téléphones
à partir de là on dit voilà il y aura
des personnalités gêne apparente
communiquer avec eux je fais juste mon
boulot et après je pars à la fin de
teaser führen chez pas d'accord donc ils
vous ont dit justifier ton travail tu
dis rien voilà on va briller sur le
service photo pas de téléphone donc
forcément au téléphone on l'enlève dès
l'arrivée on l'étend donc à l'intérieur
de la salle quand vous arrivez vous
préparez et tous ensuite il ya eu
combien d'invités qui sont arrivés alors
au début ça va au compte-gouttes n'a pas
tout le monde qui arrive à 17h30
c'est un petit à petit j'irai vraiment
vers 20h30 21h c'est là où vraiment la
salle était pleine de gérer une
quarantaine de convives quarantaine de
convives sont les serveurs on était cinq
plus les gens cuisinent d'accord
quarantaine de convives donc c'était
quoi de quatre tables de dix c'était là
c'était cinq tables
cinq tables d'accord cinq tables de 8 ch
je suis très fort a pourtant montré que
je sait calculer est-ce que cette soirée
ils étaient payantes ouais ouais
après moi sincèrement devant moi aucun
élément de fait d'accord mais j'ai vu
les menus
j'ai vu les prix affichés donc voilà
c'est tout ce que je peux le dire mais
devant moi effectivement il ya eu aucun
paiement effectué par les clients
d'accord est-ce que donc les invités
dont ils étaient une quarantaine est ce
que vous les serveurs vous aviez des
masques n'ont pas de masque pour vous
pas pour les serveurs nas qui en cuisine
non plus en cuisine certaines personnes
d'accord à tous les invités les invités
n'ont aucun risque aucun masque au kawa
et spcr avant vous avez été demandée
comment tests pcr vous avez été de
montréal où l'ajustement des parts au
vocal
j'ai dit oui tout simplement on se
demande est prof d'accord d'accord
alors est ce qu'il y avait ce qui avait
des gens connus parce qu'on vous a dit
qu'il avait des gens connus à cette
soirée
est-ce que vous avez reconnu des gens
connus oui oui vous avez reconnu quoi il
paraît qu'il est bien un animateur télé
moi je suis pas spécialiste des médias
en plus j'ai une mauvaise mémoire mais
j'ai reconnu directement une personne
c'est un animateur télé
un animateur qui a acquis a bercé mon
enfance d'accord un gros animateurs de
calvaire qui a bercé mon enfance quand
on sait que c'est pas bernard montiel
guide groupe d'animateurs nombreux
animateurs beaucoup vidéo les gentils
toi il a du goût
il ya du coup c'est réglé un groupe
d'animateurs et il y avait d'autres gens
de la télé
une autre personne était que je
connaissais mois mais que j'avais déjà
vu qu un chroniqueur un coin s'est
inclinée 4 à chroniquer ensuite quand je
me sens en forme et je sais que c'est un
chroniqueur et sylvain qui travaillent à
l'accord en ce moment tu as comme qui
encore à l'antenne en ce moment c'est
pas dans tpm pays notation c'est payant
il n'y serait jamais la réponse
directement on va pas d'un pirate
raconter d'histoire donc un chroniqueur
très connu un l'animateur télé très
connue était apparemment dans cette
soirée et certains parlent
deux ministres et d'un ministre en
particulier disque avait un ministre
dans cette soirée
alors effectivement et avait un homme
politique
d'accord après ce désastre un homme
politique sortant aux politiques moi je
suis naze vous savez pas c'est un
ministre ou pas non mais bon on vous a
dit pourquoi qu'est ce qu'on vous a dit
ça dans le serveur on sait brief un
petit peu ouais et on nous a dit
attention à cette table à c'est un homme
politique
donc faites attention à la manière de
servir à la manière de parler c'est un
homme politique en activité ou en
activité 20 ministres en activité à
l'action et à ses administrés n'ont pas
un homme politique pardon d'accord
membres du gouvernement actuel
non il a dit au mollet l'homme politique
de gauche et qui sait est très bien être
connaissez son nom je suis après a passé
un ministre oba sannum politique c'est
tout ce que je peux vous dire qu'il
s'est passé c'est un ministre ou parce
qu'il connaît pas la maintenant qu'il a
le nom il sait que le dit pas je pense
que quand on m'a montré des images j'ai
reconnu la personne d'accord j'ai voilà
je ne peux pas vous dire autre chose que
c'est une personne qui a des cheveux
gris ok ok on n'a pas quarante mille des
hommes politiques qui ont déjà
grand-mère quand même que les
gouvernements je pense ma d'accord du
gouvernement donc voilà donc c'est un
milito gouvernements locaux aura pas
donné de nom ici oui oui il est au
gouvernement ce moment ça ccsa en
activité en ce moment quand j'entendais
sur internet tous d'accord ayant observé
une activité sexe ah oui alors là c'est
ouais alors il ya pierre jean chalencon
que vous qui c'est lui qui vous a qui
vous a briefé sur la soirée ou non pas
du tout le seul moment où j'ai un
contact avec lui c'est quand même à
faire un clin d'oeil
d'accord il était plutôt cool avec vous
ses notes à clins d'oeil vous
aujourd'hui vous décidé de témoigner ce
soir pour vous avez été choqué par eux
c'est ce que même moi j'étais dans les
galets dans l'illégalité ce soir rassure
parce que d'une je travaille aux blacks
j'ai moi aussi j'ai pas respecté tout ce
qu'on découvre surtout donc moi aussi
j'ai
j'ai ma part dans cette histoire mais
quand je vois tout ce qui se passe à la
télé et je vois que je la signe même pas
ses mensonges
ce que j'ai écouté à ce qu'il a dit un
coup c'est 9 mars à la pousser dans le
personnes a coulé des ministres un coup
y'a pas le ministre un coup que
christophe leroy qui apparaissent alors
le roi christophe leroy le domicile du
chef christophe leroy vient d'être
perquisitionné ce qu'il y avait que
c'est christophe leroy qui j'avoue me
l'apprenez ça d'accord
effectivement j'ai reconnu ce chef
christophe leroy donc miser clean c'est
incroyable ce témoignage soit sur wii
berne a monté un petit mot je voudrais
simplement dire que sauf le roi a été
découvert par est débarqué il ya quand
même plus de 20 ans à saint tropez
et puis il a été le chef aussi de johnny
a travaillé avec johnny géniale idée là
beaucoup lancée et après il a ouvert
tout un tas de restaurants qui
s'appelait la table du marché et là une
très très grande notoriété c'est vrai
ces affaires ont périclité livré aussi
et du coup il a monté son business club
comme ça où il fait des dîners union moi
à la base je ne connaissais pas du tout
ça c'est après cette sortie d'affaires
j'ai vu son visage
effectivement je le reconnais selon
retrouver voici mes reins leroy merlin a
observé gilles verdez pourquoi pourquoi
les enquêteurs qui s'intéressent à lui
c'est parce que leur présomption
d'innocence total bien sûr mais on
soupçonne effectivement que dans ces
soirées qui était organisée très
régulièrement
tout était en liquide il y avait
plusieurs menus proposés moi j'ai les
menus à un menu qui s'appelle christophe
l'euro il a faim menu pour bondir sur ce
que disait bernard le menu hommage à
johnny hallyday 290 euros par personne
qui était vendu dans certaines de ces
soirées là ça va loin voilà il est
derrière vous la sas était bondée et on
le sent on le soupçonne effectivement
d'avoir récupéré en liquide l'argent des
échanges monnaie faire passer par là et
c'est autour de lui autour de
l'organisation de ces soirées que les
soupçons des enquêteurs sans ce moment
en train de se focaliser voilà oui
gilles en quoi le prix du menu fait que
c'est chaud comme ça je ne comprends pas
regardons en quoi le prix du menu remet
flex et même souvent on s'en foutra non
s'en fout pas si on s'en fout moi j'ai
absolument se sert de cette affaire il
ya un restaurateur qui a ouvert son
restaurant en janvier à nice devant les
caméras tout le monde l'applaudît c'est
un acte de rébellion
là parce que c'est des gens soi disant
puissant et aisée comme servant
chalencon ont leur tombe dessus en
finale en caméra cachée tout en
maintenant le restera soeur ida il a
convoqué la presse pour dire j'ai besoin
de bosser
il a fait un acte
il a déjà fait un acte pour dire je ne
l'appelais on s'en fout la 12e' on s'en
fout bruno notre serveur à la soirée de
paix en chalencon donc il y avait donc
une quarantaine de personnes vous me
dites 8 portable la soirée là démarre à
quelles heures à 17h30 c'est fini
seulement il ya quelques convives qui
sont arrivés au début c'était un petit
cocktail sites au total déboursé la
coupe de champagne on se fait la bise
est tout petit à petit ça s'installe à
table et là il ya eu effectivement j'ai
entendu à la télé que jean perf en
charge de leurs discours son discours
elle a duré 15 minutes et pas 40 minutes
comme il a dit donc il a fait un
discours aussi bien qu'à un petit
discours à ce qu'il a dit mais il parle
de la crise dans ce moment clé il est
pressé que ça se termine mais en nous
quand j'entendis parler des
bicentenaires de la paix n'est pas
d'accord on may a pas eu le bicentaire
ya plus de débit sauter c'est pas une
soirée test alors mais alors les
personnes qui étaient s.koné c'est ou
bien c'est toujours un dîner où il
faisait rencontres et débats où il la
plupart se connaissait c'était faisait
la bise bon préparer nous on est censé
être un peu discret un peu un peu rauque
il donc on voit quand même ce qui se
passe c'est bon il y en a qui se
présentent et voilà je te présente elle
a interpellé tous mais la plupart se
connaissent et ouais d'accord le
ministre il était une table avec eux
frêche dit le ministre parce que c'est
une des dix membres du gouvernement il
était une table avec pierre-jean
chalencon il était une table avec
d'autres passagers par action la vérité
est là je vais pas mentir et à inventer
des histoires
d'accord je sais juste valeur on nous a
dit ça at elle table et un homme
politique et où j'ai essayé avec la
production
votre équipe de contacter la fille qui
les a servis pour avoir des preuves
malheureusement elle par crainte de
laval a refusé toute interview s'il
s'avère qu'il ya un ministre dans le dos
et que je risque quoi c'est une affaire
d'état
il a été dit d'ailleurs par les plus
hautes autorités par monsieur darmanin
qu' il devrait démissionner là on
en tant qu dans l' affaire d'état bien
sûr qu'il a des il est encore en poste
ou pas oui ça certains certains n'ont
pas quitté le gouvernement c'est vrai
certains par contre justement moi aussi
je suis jeune et c'est pour discuter de
ça parce que il ya eu quelques mois
quelques mois de ça une histoire par
rapport à des magistrats qui avaient
mangé dans le restaurant
sincèrement j'en ai plus entendu parler
c'est pour ça que je suis là parce que
même si je me dis là je vais vous parler
ils vont ils vont dormir la faire parce
que quoi parce que cette histoire les
vrais des vous avez déjà vous travaillez
dans d'autres restaurants clandestins
avec des vagues ce train il moi non mais
l'ami qui m'a branché justement sur
cette soirée-là lui a l'habitude de ça
d'accord vous savez qu'il ya des soirées
incroyables en ce moment et je vous dis
ouais je vous lis il ya des trucs fous
qui se passe actuellement en france il
ya même des gens qui font des soirées
ils appellent ça des soirées fighter
c'est à dire que je vous lis moins c'est
incroyable s'est il n'en faut que j'aie
qui est absolument incroyable c'est les
gens qui appellent ça des soirées kaiser
c'est à dire qu'ils sont une vingtaine
de personnes qui se réunissent dans un
appartement et qui se font vacciner
voilà un moyennant finances
donc j'ai dit ces foules en train
d'enquêter également là dessus mais
c'est vrai que ce serait incroyable
voile à bord ça et là la halle pour le
coup c'est vrai que voilà le
gouvernement elle peut faire tout ce
qu'il peut malheureusement quand il ya
des gens qui se comportent comme ça
c'est comme pendant la prohibition
c'est incroyable et en ce moment je vous
le dis c'est la course au vaccin
c'est la course à et chez un pote qui
connaît un pote qui est un vaccin qui
est un truc et je vous dis cette soirée
c'est soir et faiseurs ces jeunes il les
appelle comme ça c'est juste incroyable
voilà ça se passe actuellement en france
et ça aussi il faut le gouvernement et
peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent mais un
moment s'il ya des mecs qui font tout
pour essayer de 2 à 2,2 de risque y est
de faire de magouiller vous pourra pas
non plus s'en sortir oui
et est ce que ça vous a semblé être un
dîner exceptionnel ou où c'est une
coutume
toutes les semaines tous les vendredis
les gens que vous avez des bosses et
viennent bosser régulièrement là bas où
c'était vraiment parce que apparemment
c'était un événement exceptionnel non
d'un comme vous et moi c'était la
première fois que je mets mon ami qu'à
l'habitude de faire ça ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'il est d'accord donc
c'est donc c'est assez récurrent chez
rubis avait écrit balle ça vous fini
comment ils ont tous danser les uns avec
les autres le ministre samedi déjà la
production je suis parti à 22h30 pile on
m'a payée en cash
déjà donc je suis parti mais je sais que
quand je pense à 22h36 avait encore du
monde effectivement est mon ami qui m'a
branché sur ce coup là a fait une
réception pareil au mois de février
un cocktail et il m'a dit qu'il y avait
une fuite sécrète story dedans à travers
oui c'est ce qu'on avait vu on a vu les
photos 1 voilà et on devrait la halle à
la route si on devait la recevoir un des
gars parce qu'on a vu les photos oui je
le redis j'ai une question
oui j'ai une question monsieur sur
l'attitude du ministre est ce que à un
moment de la soirée il a paru gênés 1 se
cachant un peu parce que peut-être y
mesurer les conséquences où il était au
contraire très à l'aise non pas du tout
de l'été normale après quand je me suis
renseigné
quand j'ai vu tout ce qui se passe et
que je ne se renseigner vous dire la
vérité c'est pas c'est pas le premier
ministre sait quoi d'autre part le
ministre quand même un peu plus discret
donc c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il
s'est dit que les gens vont pas me
reconnaître
d'accord dit est ce qu'il y avait un
service de sécurité particulier dehors
dedans vous les services de sécurité
d'accord son horizon se fait contrôler
wibert dans ce qui est sûr c'est que
s'il y avait vraiment un ministre comme
vous le dites c'est très grave et il va
se faire virer direct sincèrement je
pense moi aussi mais vous verrez c'est
triste sur marlène schiappa l'a dit
monsieur d'arman amis de l'intérieur l'a
dit le mec se faire virer direct c'est
inadmissible ça va pas être est il
admissible mais nicolas pernikoff
pourquoi vous dites je ne pense pas
quand je vous ai dit tout à l'heure par
rapport à l'histoire des magistrats et
qui avait dîné qu'avec des jeunes et je
reçois mes enfants je pense que
peut-être qu'il va se manger une petite
amende mais
je vais vous dire je vais vous dire il
ya regarder voilà l'entourage de jean
castex à communiquer auprès de rtl dans
la tête du premier ministre les choses
sont très claires
s'il s'avérait qu'un mini s'était rendu
dans ce type de soirée ce serait la
démission direct mais voila voila je
pense que là c'est sûr oui j'ai levé le
témoignage est incroyable le témoignage
qu'on a ce soir est incroyable parce que
c est la première fois qu est avérée par
un témoin direct
la présence d'un ministre du
gouvernement donc vous avez tout à fait
raison de témoigner monsieur avait
justement en même temps je lance un
appel à tous mes collègues qui étaient
là ce jour là pour pouvoir aussi de
témoin les têtes qui risquent quelque
chose comme moi parce que j'ai travaillé
aux blacks et tout et je n'avais pas le
droit de travailler ou à eux aussi je
demande qu'ils viennent parler comme
vous pourriez aller plus alizés dit
est-ce que vous accepteriez ça va sans
doute arriver de d'être entendu par la
police et par les moines y est parce que
l' enquête qui a été lancée au départ
par milliers de l'intérieur va emporter
là dessus aussi qu'ils étaient là je
pense que vous avez la réponse
aujourd'hui mon visage je suis pas très
fort en sensations
non là c'est vrai il ya plein de gens
corps qui le disons mais pourquoi vous
faites tout ça comme vous et 10 et je
trouve ça honteux que des gens qui
pensent avoir un peu de pouvoir font ça
et surtout après quand j'étais allé là
j'ai déjà entendu le jeune alex
ouais bon je vois plus le pauvre
issement je sais trés 200 euros
d'amende- presse et que le bas pour
l'instant ils sont trente chine
franchement je suis encore plus cher
aujourd'hui de venir et de dénoncer ça
oui quelqu'un qui peut risquer à
l'animateur télé
est ce que c'est un gros animateur télé
aujourd'hui en activité cyril vous savez
vous où est-ce qu'il peut ne plus avoir
de travail comme une amende on va
dépendre ça dépend de la chaîne après
qui prend cette grosse scène l'animateur
télé dont j'ai parlé oui et les puits en
exercice d'accord d'accord très bien que
c'est un gros animal terminer plus haut
niveau seul le chroniqueur est encore en
exercice le chroniqueur est encore dans
la finition le chroniqueur il est en
exercice sur une chaîne prochaine on
peut dire ça on peut dire c'est un
chemin mother c'est la chaîne publique
adacore abritera oui donc c'est france 2
a entendu les matins ou france 5
oui moi ça me choque pas justement qu'un
animateur télé hi à un de saisine et moi
ce qui me choque c'est qu'un ministre y
aille parce que ce sont des gens qui
passent leur journée à vous bien nous
faire la morale et nous dire ne faites
pas s'ils ne fait pas ça à mettre des
amendes comme vous l'avez dit en plus
aux plus démunis donc ça c'est
dégueulasse mais après que des gens
viennent moi ça ne me choque pas mais
qu'un ministre soit oui jb rebelles je
comprends pas du tout guillon vous
rendez pas compte je crois c'est
vraiment on a l'impression que des
privilégiés se paye un repas vont dîner
dans l'illégalité et alors que les gens
alors que les gens ne peuvent pas sortir
sont calfeutrés chez eux couvre-feu
presque confinement et vous vous êtes en
train de vous dire que c'est normal
pourquoi pas à les attendre et les gens
mais les gens qui voient ça moi je suis
d'accord avec le monsieur avec le
serveur les gens qui vous assaillent
c'est déjà une france à deux vitesses je
suis les privilégiés planqué nous qui
souffrons arrêtez enfin je dis pas ça je
dis quoi si l'insee renom vous comprenez
pas ce que je dis mais d'irizar devrait
pouvoir aller au restaurant comme c'est
le cas dans plein de pays mais personne
ne s'est plaint de pays dans le monde et
je veux dire que oui c'est dégueulasse
que quelqu'un qui passe ses journées à
faire l'amour elle a donné des sueurs
puisse y aller mais je dis que tout le
monde devrait pouvoir sortir et aller au
restaurant bernard nord sinon c'est
clairement intolérable on se fait
toucher avec ce bien sûr que oui alors
lé sentiment faire ils vont gâcher je
sais pas ou non mais franchement c'est
intolérable
moi ça m'énerve il faut vraiment qu'ils
soient tous pour passer un autre immense
qu'on note c'est que ça devait
soi-disant se terminer à 22 heures avec
des personnes et que c'est à 22h30 ça
n'était pas fini et qu'ils étaient plus
de 40 qu'elle est effectivement ministre
en fait vous apporter les réponses à
toutes les questions qu'on se pose
depuis trois jours et moi moi moi je
vais vous dire moi je moi c'est pas pire
jean chalon sombre qui me lever non non
kim noorda kimvula benneteau c'est ce
qu' ils sont allés oui c'est quand même
il faut quand même vraiment je vous dis
la vérité
faut quand même être complètement à
bruit franchement en ce moment avec une
soirée 40 personnes
faut vraiment y aller pour vrai régal il
faut vraiment être géré a dit je vous
poser une question à ce que gabriel à
talas est épinglé et marlène schiappa a
dit il a reçu effectivement une
invitation mais il a décliné mais vous
vous trouvez pas que c'est enfin vous
serez pas ça aberrant que gabri à
l'attaqué porte parole du gouvernement
ne prennent pas la parole peut être pas
lui mais quelqu'un de son de son
ministère ou de son cabinet en disant
mais attend des lanceurs d'alerté
on n'a pas le droit de faire des fêtes
on n'a pas le droit de faire des restos
clandestins j'ai pas il lui demandera
gabriel adams
à la télévision il pourrait en prime et
au moins dire mais vous devez pas faire
ça mais on lui aura d'ailleurs s'il l'a
fait vous avez
pour ces messieurs pardon vous témoigner
à visage couvert donc pourquoi garder le
mystère au final qu'est ce que vous
risquez concrètement à dire la vérité
mais il la dit la vérité la vérité des
noms il veut pas l'éloge des noms des
dons merci il peut les dire exemple mais
pourquoi il ne le dit pas on va demander
le palais le dire mais bon je dis pas
non plus qu'on a suffisamment l'aider à
les dire puis il a été payée au noir
donc comme il l'a dit oui à l'heure donc
savoir délicat en tout cas ça fait
parlons en mais ça fait jusque là que
toute la presse et de tous les médias
depuis cinq jours ça moi je vous dit
personnellement j'aimerais bien le
savoir qu à ça maintenant ça va sentir
ça va 100 ça les mecs mais on est on est
au bord là on vient vous venez monsieur
de provoquer ce qui va être une affaire
d'état c'est pas lui non mais je dis ça
respectueusement il se passe ici une
affaire d'état c'est à dire que le
gouvernement va devoir réagir très vite
à ça c'est sûr sûr c'est sûr et le nom
du ministre va sortir dans les viviers
gouvernement aussi dessus et je pense
que le gouvernement va à huy agir très
vite parce que ils peuvent pas laisser
sa danseuse comme ça au jeu merci en
tout cas merci s'amariner l'inversé
merci pour votre témoignage on espère
vous n'aurez pas de problème je sais ce
qu'on espère et vous avez eu raison
garder l'anonymat parce qu'on espère
voilà que vous allez pouvoir
retravailler et retrouver une activité
prochainement et une activité clé air
ball à ipsen et son sens non pas dans
des restaurants qu'on destin